[Music]
wake up Yanis tell you something what is
it vengo fall off the ladder
no taka exile you at dawn I knew this
day would come
demand a trial a trial by one-on-one I
will be your champion good oh you're a
good kid it's not right they blame you
for everything the analytics maesters
blame you for other countries we give up
I mean it is my defensive schemes and
the fan links says your fault we don't
know what to foul in the last two
minutes of battle okay I mean that even
though have denied I've given up on you
11 of them actually yeah breakfast
smoothie time I could adjust my schemes
I could stop blaming our youth I could
even work on my time management but I
won't because at the end of the day I
must be true to who I am in here and in
here I am an [ __ ]
I'm a stubborn [ __ ] and I don't have
a clue what I'm doing with what's your
service Lord Commander I've ever had I'm
the only Lord Commander you've ever
heard where did you have Larry jewelry
you jewellary do for you yes Oh Clara
what's matter is the size not fair what
they told you you're giving up on us
you're giving up on me don't cry over
spilled meaty honest life gives you
spilled meat using together a few
timeout the big dog Glenn Robinson when
aus box finest nights I fought beside
him under our socks years ago Luke
Amanda never talked about him but
sometimes I'd find him down here
lighting candles and praying to the
statue
those weren't prayers they were curses
sir Glenn Robinson was the first pick of
his draft glass do you know who was
second locomotor hi my laksa Lord
Commander
they would come down here to pay as
disrespects that resent him that anger
our circuits greatest weapon and his
greatest weakness
we were just getting comfortable in a
scheme so Ray Allen it was pretty
comfortable fighting under George Karl I
spent years on the brink of conquer in
the east together but they never did
things grew toxic five years later ray
was finally a champion under maester
rivers his sex Lord Commander his an
assert Jordan was a great night underdog
Collins but it was under the Zen master
that he became a champion
don't forget about stiff carry Mike come
on Shirley he was quite comfortable with
Mike Jackson but Steve Kerr really put
him over the top
what are you even doing down here I was
just standing here scrapping around
actually found a pretty cool cave you
guys want to come check this out what is
this place this must be pre-merger new
house Hawks maybe on our start is that
real disturbing him my George Mikan the
first giant
what is this look at all these pairs
walls oh my gosh Greece must be a white
man in a forest probably heard about
them in stories they were the first to
play this game looks normal to me look
here
no three-point line
they were too weak to shoot over here
some of these guys weren't even for time
nights there were tooth wasters and they
weren't playing and this there must be
thousands of years old
oh look over here this guy's holding a
basket this looks like their birdie is
trying oh yeah that must be Meister
Naismith Wow legend has it he settled
baller Osen made our holy spot
he's the father of us all there yeah
look it says he thou maker that's him
does the start saw mater
well Jason how old did you say this was
again
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]